shimizu who are very happy to announce
eight unanimous agreement on these
fishing possibilities this is an
important agreement for the
sustainability of stocks in the Baltic
Sea but at the same time for the fishing
economy in these countries the most
complicated issues revolved around the
cod stocks for boats docks we decided in
the end on sizeable quoted reductions by
twenty percent each and on a package of
measures to accompany the recovery of
those important resources I am
optimistic that the considerable
reduction of catches decided today will
put us on a path to recovery we have
given a signal today that Europe
supports its vicious as they face the
fallout from the continuing Russian
embargo lacock panthea Polly cop21 in
Paris is fast approaching and there is
no doubt that agriculture has an
important role to play in mitigating
climate change agriculture like forestry
is the only economic sector which both
issues and reduces greenhouse gases the
agriculture sector therefore must face a
duel challenge